what the hell is going on welcome to
what throw squeak oh hey that's
officially how we search is that we
can't use for their copyright yeah so
hey this is our first episode hi hi nice
to meet you you might be familiar with
us from such videos as Game of Thrones
breakdown season 6 episode 1 you might
be familiar with this mod garrett from
geek balm yes season all this time 5
years 5 years old yeah thank you Huggies
of oh my gosh as of like today what yeah
good on that
so the two of us are huge Game of
Thrones fans yeah and we recently here
on new rockstars did a poll asking what
kind of content you guys wanted to see
if we started making more things and hey
turns out lucky for us you said Game of
Thrones after-show oh yeah
the two biggest fans of Game of Thrones
in the office and then Eric's gonna get
mad at me sitting over there because
he's also a huge fan of p.m. its own
we're going to go through the episode
we're going to give some reactions to it
we have some predictions about next week
we're going to answer a lot of your
questions you guys asked us with the
hashtag Westeros weekly really good
questions as well I think all you guys
what guys uh ma I'm going to bring some
up throughout but I'm also going to have
a whole Q&A section at the end so moving
forward you guys got to get used to a
couple things you guys do every week one
is you guys got to answer our poll each
week of who you think was the most
influential who's got the power this
week and then that'll help play into our
rankings mm can we talk for a taste like
no we're going to talk into that yeah I
extreme but then also you're going to
have to do your TAS every week with that
hashtag we talked about earlier and
that'll all be incorporated in the show
because really it shows a conversation
between us and you guys yay yay season
seven episode one it went down last
night I watched it by myself
but I took my notes in my trusty note
market invited in my placement watch it
take a little antistick night okay I
will furthermore do you are lonely okay
good it's just in I wasn't done buddy
yes there you go my god
okay my dragons because I'm a mother of
dragons obviously thank you very much
see how not bad back week not me
first up we're just going to kind of
give you our gut reactions the things
that we can't not talk about I mean for
me personally we got to talk about what
happened right at the beginning what a
killer way to start this episode now
when it did like a previously on game of
thrones that atria loves to do thank
goodness it kind of talked about how
this was almost a dream how you know the
throat slitting happened so again while
watching Walder Frey it was so obvious
that the glasses were filled with poison
and he's like drank our best our best
bath going around not you and as soon as
he said no this is very good I want you
to do more water yeah I told you I was
good on there how do I know I'm really
good at running and sewing it was
obvious that the poisoning was happening
because like it's just another dream
this is another fantasy that Ari has got
washes on the road well I know who is
also lonely it's all it does have that
element where it's like you know we're
used to magic we stood ragged resist
such insane things here and it's like
okay we got real like disguised space
which of course is from the faceless men
so it's not in the lair nowhere but with
like voice modulation but yes you know
she's just a master of now I guess jock
and taught her that too
when you put on the face you become the
person yeah I liked it I liked the idea
that jock and in our world is just like
the top comedian in the world he's like
just as amazing impersonation it's just
joking we realized though that Aria now
has she's gonna submit able force she
took out the entire male Frey population
just by mimicking one person of power so
now you realize that she could do
amazing things and she's a real like
schematic person now she can figure out
who to be at the right time to cause the
most destruction and she I think one of
the most dangerous things she has
vengeance
here's a list and that's probably the
most important thing right now and she's
got to get through this list at whatever
cost and she's doing it like Hugh in big
big degrade right and we're going to get
into Aria even more in a little
it I heard the journey that she's going
to go on and also in Eric's video which
again by the way Eric's breakdowns are
still going to happen they're going to
have certain one delicious diabetes
embolism and were you eating it that's
the same your honor you eat it they had
no knowledge they do you hear it's mom
mom come on Garrett 2017 so we're going
to really get into in that video
who aria is representing and not just in
Westeros but in Westeros a religion
which pretty cool yes but what her
you're like oh this moment killed me
anytime says he spoke oh it killed me
she is so deluded she is like a couple
she feels like she should unstoppable at
the moment and she completely caught up
in the rapture of power because she's
finally got the crown on her own head
she thinks that nothing bad can happen
and Jamie is back by her side which I
thought was a little shocking as well
because he has just been toyed around
lately it's clearly saying you know
she's like you know we are in charge of
the Seven Kingdoms use like we've got
three at best and she's just like
dismisses that completely so any kind of
sound advice coming her way
she's ignoring it she's just
power-hungry and it's going to be the
death of her oh how sweet how soon
though that's what we don't know right
she is embracing the mad queen title and
it's like when I'm playing a video game
I decide you know what I'm gonna run the
track as fast as I can and it's like oh
my god I got further than I ever did and
then I died worse than I ever did yeah I
think she's playing a very dangerous
game yeah she's burning every bridge
which is on the throne
did she light it yeah for this to chop
off another so for me probably the mean
the moment that I had the strongest gut
reaction to was that freaking montage of
Sam why did they do that to us the soup
in the poop I just in this group and
then soup in the poop and the soup in
the poop I was like it was added in the
fresh super rich soup in a poop in a
rush I feel like was edited by Edgar
Wright thank you sorry Silas like oh
look at all these yellow soaps and smell
and we're going to make it a soundtrack
and you don't know whether you want to
vomit or what's happy figure I mean
kudos to the editor of the
for cutting directly from the pupal that
is exactly the same as a suitable hole I
mean yacht department must be like oh my
god I love that idea that though the
prop guys like I'm going to make dragon
teeth this season or something cool now
like no no Nanette and I wear your new
quick Stan that's poop yeah good luck
Hershey bar oh it was real poo guys Matt
wasn't oh we don't know that's
railrunner that's what what got me the
most a moment I'm very intrigued about
is the vision that Brian had right at
the top of the episode of the night King
walking I have huge questions about that
I'm going to move some of them over to
the Q&A section the same visions that I
found is seeing as well slightly like
what if the hounds vision is happening
this slightly different moment right but
honestly I think because just because he
saw the wall as well but he also it
sounded like it was a Eastwatch we'll
get to it
speaking of locations which was a huge
team step aside by the way was geography
welcome to our board thing that I stayed
up all night making welcome to the met
of waitress did we add applause Wow so
what we're going to do with this map
here is we're going to be able to
actually check in on very specific parts
of video geography and where people are
so the Northeast I'm obviously been the
huge point of it though the wall
separating the army that's coming down
the undead army but also they're gaining
forces as well which is huge because
Castle black has never really had anyone
except the Nights Watch there right well
for a very long time in the hundred
managee said one of my favorite things
that's going on at the wall potentially
by the way is just three folks taking
over all the different castles and
they're like haha table to turn because
the Nights Watch became obsessed with
the idea of stopping the people from
coming south of the wall and so they
forgot that their initial duty which is
up the White Walkers from coming and now
it's all kind of coming back to them
like oh damn we were worried about the
wrong people but it's just a nice little
ironic moment that they're going to be
the new like nice watch I love that and
a little fun fact as well like the whole
Tolman story arc
apparently that little flirt moment that
everyone became obsessed with last
season was done no it wasn't even I said
like improvising totally directly Zetian
and I realized oh yeah Brienne should
totally find love with you know the free
folk yeah let's start look we do a plain
one just for sex
just because we're already up here I do
want to point out so we had brand he
arrived at the wall thank god this guy
can actually have a real bed and a real
fire in a real place to stay and Mira
need some time off because poor thing
she's all she's done is just drag this
you know unless you've been dragging him
through the entirety of the project
literal excuse me like oh my back is
sore from carrying you I love the moment
by the way really quick where Edie's
like how do I know you're your brand
stark and he's like the darkest night is
coming to whatever and he's like oh yeah
you're just not like that like I know
you guys are related he knows his stuff
he's grown up he's a little bad boy
anymore is he I specifically have
noticed when child actors grow up they
grow up you you expecting to grow up the
way you did so it's like oh I can go
from like a kid to like a you know
awkward kid and like no they have the
best like dermatologists in the world
whatever he's just like becoming just
handsome little guys like that's not
making tens of thousands of dollars in a
society it's not more it's like the the
kids from Modern Family gorgeous
I've never seen an episode of that show
you have not there's no dragon - I know
how would you know
so someone had a great question on
Twitter that I think now would be a good
time to ask they want to know where
we've had white Walker sightings just
general where has that past God and off
Benjen oh where is he I would love some
cold hands right now really go to mighty
Hansberry anywhere by the way to the
song that EDF and Sharon sang so we'll
get to him later
so when the show opens we had a white
Walker sighting just in the haunted
forest yeah it was Sir Waymar Royce was
out there and he's the one we actually
see them like it's the very first thing
we ever see on the show a lot of people
forget is White Walkers attacking people
white and that's happening as they're
scavenging in the the haunted forest so
that's right up there now later in the
show is that seriously called the face
to the Sussman yeah the first bit so
later in the show
actually that is where we have another
encounter except the show didn't really
have the budget to show it yet but so
that's where Sam see the the whites and
I believe Sam gets saved if I remember
by the Lord Commander at the time yeah
but that's our next sighting of the
white Walker so that kind of makes sense
that in the haunted forest they're down
there benefits of the first man how they
feel at home in the haunted forest right
I wonder if they named it first or like
it eventually oh just like you know what
is the spooky let's call ohonta yeah so
then Craster's keep which is going all
right now yeah what an awful guy this is
obviously the guy he really stuck with
his daughters come on yeah and then gave
us the great character a Gilly thanks to
that Thank You Craster but you know he
would sacrifice the men the boys that
were born so they there are no men
really the better boys and boys who
don't care about the night skin I would
take them yeah and just like do a little
like oh man I just remembered that's so
similar to a rap group bug bomb
thugs-n-harmony the video where death
comes and he like takes a baby up into
his arms and they walk up a mountain and
I'm gonna miss everybody you had told me
to be wrong Persephone Czar's in harmony
yeah I think no one is the right person
to talk to about that so anyway crafters
peep there is that sighting like you
said away cases all right so we've had
right the haunted forest this is the
first men and then Craster's keep
yep now what's weird is the wall is
right there but instead our next
sighting is all the way at the tip of
this peninsula that's where hardhome was
now hardhome is where that insane battle
was we're hiding down the ravine it
wasn't it was a mutt my boy miguel
splash Nick directed that one favorite
director of the show that was the
scariest the white walkers have ever
been when you finally saw like just how
many numbers there are right how fast
they are because you know you'd really
be like the zombies the feel they're not
threatening if they can't move fast
these guys were sprinting down they're
violent they attack they're killers is
when we realize that like oh they have
their strength they have everything back
the skeletons are fast if they're faster
than everything yeah they're not zombies
no right there is a human threat and
then of course you know there was a huge
amount of deaths that happened at
hardhome
not many people survived ever they tried
to fight and anyone that did die we're
risen yeah that's exactly
he did I guess but that moment where you
rise all those people pays off in
division we see in the vision if you
look closely those people are wearing a
lot of free fault furs and that's where
we have our Giants from - so the
deadwood that actually won one or was it
a giant we don't know if it would top it
faces a skeleton now that one one D
factor plays one one was credited for
the episode and I on IMDB it said one
one but I'm to be is not the most
reliable source he was missing an eye
which one one lost an eye in a battle
that is one one but it's the other I was
Mira it's a vision rear-vision mirror in
genera you mean Mira had a vision
sure Mira vision ah you are stepping up
to the pun plate alright well um mr. one
two pun one one two one one put I need a
sec hey we got a car what's really
interesting about that
that I was pointing out though is they
didn't go to the wall they were going
down and then they went way up there to
their Florida not all of them did
obviously we realize there are thousands
upon thousands do they have filled yeah
they just kind of like looking around
trying to kill more things before they
are I commanded you to join forces yes
is my guess yeah so that's what's really
interesting with what they've decided
right over there you see Eastwatch east
watch is where we meet the sea is where
potentially we later see the how and
having the vision or we never see that
land available
well they're arriving at the wall ELISA
and there's vision but so East watch to
hardhome that's about 150 miles okay I
hardhome try the flags about 300 150
miles is close as hell you can do that
in three days not all of them I on
horses
yeah they walk I'm gonna say two miles
per hour so this is when my brain starts
going I need to make sense of this I
don't need to brief I can run forever
cuz I just run the whole one I think
that's that's not saying that they don't
run forever they very clearly do the
slow march slower than your average
human and you know what when people take
their time getting some way it's because
they have a plan mm-hmm they're not in a
rush you know I know exactly I'm gonna
do
also it's an unstoppable force that is
just like what's going to get in
destruction by the way that's the night
king sigil a lot of people haven't seen
that but he's headed south anyway then a
little further down at Winterfell
I guess we got to talk about what was
supposed to be drama
if Littlefinger had his way and it
wasn't the most drama this doesn't know
this is the power play that's changed a
little bit Peter always knows how to
place cards where he can be in charge of
a situation where he can actually move
the chess pieces and in this case chance
has just given him a big fat no yeah I I
love that too I also love specifically I
don't like when characters that
shouldn't be fighting just fight and
it's like why guys just just have a
conversation and they did and I thinking
is well I'm still worried about the rest
of season if it doesn't end up that way
and Peter does get as well I mean if you
get bent he's going to bring out the
Peter becquer
yes she does here's a bird's digital
yeah she'll show yes I actually I'm
starting a hashtag peace off PETA oh
good I like him oh it's off can I say
that in America yes good if it means I'm
not aware of them no not the same thing
Chuck um so of course we had our scene
stealer Lyanna Mormont there who's every
time amazing she's one of the best
written characters ever and I love the
fact that she's just school and grown
men all around her and then it says like
this thing where if you are a lady and
if you are in charge of what you say
goes which in both each case is scary
but in Lady Vermont's case is fantastic
like she is what I call bearable she's
from Bear Island that was mod season and
I explained them but it is you know a
big thing for Jon to ask which is every
single person 10 to 16 is a huge range
of people must take up arms women and
men and of course I'm going oh you
trying to send my granddaughter to
battle and you know ready to get some
flak back and she's just like a zipper
I'm going to do it and I'm doing it she
can do it and I think that power play is
phenomenal and that's what the the north
need right we're going to get into that
a little bit in the in the breakdown of
when the situation has been so dire in
our own history that even like women and
children are picking up arms I still
love that that actress was not meant to
be such a big role and they were just
like she's amazing we have to write her
up bigger
but mostly here obviously we got to talk
about our boy John so John is one of the
characters that I actually want to dive
into our characters art that we're going
to see throughout the season so this
graphic is going to be updated as we go
right now see we've completed episode 1
episode 2 kind of just that arc and I
just want to talk about what we're
setting up right here in this it was
really much a setup episode but but we
were setting up as where John is now
what his goal is where he wants to go
John for me it just seems like he needs
a full night's sleep he just seems
exhausted the poor guy died last season
and then came back and then pretty
relaxing though when he died and came
back I wish I could this must sound
sleepy over good oh my god that's really
scary - I drink that out loud on camera
but what I find a key does need someone
else to help him out and he's lost a lot
of trust and faith in people because
people that were supposed to do the best
by him killed him so I think that still
kind of room sitting poorly with him but
he's like it's such an apprehensive
leader right yes I'm the king of it all
right so that's I think where we're
finding him is he's honest effectively a
throne but it's almost a throne made of
like dominoes right I like him like very
delicate he's not even sure if he wants
it yeah and what he wants is very clear
he just wants people to pay attention to
the white one her problem yeah but what
it sounds like you read his trajectory
is going to be as one embracing being a
leader and like actually wanted to be
and not repeating the mistakes of his
past of his family and we've already
seen that happen where you know he's
such a like he's at Ned Stark's son he's
metal technically no all right yeah he's
written been raised on those values no
circle with his father not his daddy
there's Dale way around that like was a
daddy not a song anywhere daddy like
done it used to mean something not weird
I know I started a lot of different ways
that have been taken banners and thrust
back us up maybe hmm
so a really fascinating thing that
happens with John there is the fact that
he says I don't want to punish people
for the mistakes of their fathers yeah
their family and a few rotten apples
essentially one fascinating because John
has suffered that unfortunately because
people thought he was the bad
sort of Ned Stark alive he'll Catelyn
was really mean to him awful because of
something that Ned theoretically did but
she was mean to him so I think he's
feeling that there but then also it's
going to be really interesting because
if he's going to join up with a
Targaryen
so Daenerys is Grandfather killed John
grandfather and his uncle right and it's
and also was the Mad King like he was a
terrible person that art Gehringer awful
time and yet he is going to be ok with
potentially teaming up with her we'll
see clean blade sorry st. so I think
that's actually why they're both kind of
level-headed coming in wide actually
makes great Union but then you see
sounds like here going no you need to
real like not just firm but fair you
need to reroute rule Harley yeah what it
answers a question that I that I
actually let's bring up from a viewer is
Sansa going to become like Cersei
absolutely I had this in my notes
actually which I thought was a great
thing Sansa thirsty even saying it is a
similar thing she should this is when we
realized that she wasn't just an idol
standing by seeker she was an observer
and she was absorbing all of what she
saw and Cersei would just be so rude and
just kind of pick on her in these ways
going on you know you're so innocent
you're so you've got no idea and I think
that after being taught by Peter to
establish like the powerplay move and
like the actual game of Thrones doing a
drink she went back and kind of went
through all of Sophie's
rulings in a way and was like right now
I get a leader he just blossomed and all
of a sudden everything clicked and it
made sense and she's seen John do and
she's like cool you keep doing that
you'll die it's as simple as that
and we notice that when she was when she
did interject when John was making his
decision and she challenged that the
whole the murmurs of everyone in
Winterfell were just like yeah yeah
that's what we need to do and then he
shut it down and so you're like you got
to listen to your people as well
sometimes you've got to go to crack the
whip yeah but I'm on John's side two
reasons here one you don't question the
king while he's talking in front of the
boys they're going to question him if do
you think that thump is going to play
the busted cut do you think he's okay
you know what I've seen you try it's not
working this isn't actually your right
to be ruling here I'm
lady Sansa I am I think if that comes up
it'll come up right around the time that
John finds out his true heritage hmm but
uh okay but so Santa's a character very
clearly is going to be a major character
art that she's gonna have this season so
where are we finding her right now
I feel like she's power adjacent yes you
know I understand she's working with
John and that conversation that they had
you know when you do have an argument
you talk it out and you come to a
solution which is fantastic I think they
kind of found a lot of compromise there
which is just like listen to me is that
Eisley the worst thing that you could do
if some of the makers perhaps I could be
wrong right so she so she's um all
potential energy right ready to Xu I
feel like since the moment that she came
down the stairs in the black dress way
back when I would called her black swans
oh yeah oh my gosh she has been kind the
same thing sir she did by the way again
comparison to issued pretty becoming
Cersei Cersei Don's the black when she
saw it is saneras in this episode she's
wearing the black as well with the same
structured shoulders and this dragon is
almost so it starts on now at a point
which like oh yeah I'm supposed to lead
and then it's like Oh what where's my
throne honestly we need to kill a game
of Thrones they've positioned it where
it's women fighting against women Dany
versus thirsty versus who I think will
be some fire I think Jon tried it he
doesn't want it someone that really
knows that they could lead and want to
lead but she did make a point though
where she said to John you know this
looks really good on you you're actually
really good yeah well she's a good
person still um for now for now exactly
where we're finding her is that she's
powered Jason I'm gonna say her want is
not a seat at the table
it's secretly I think her want is the
head of stable yes absolutely
what will be interesting with Petyr
Baelish is finding out if she knew the
Vale and if that's going to be a key
component into her rule in the north and
that will come at a price which is what
your on trying to tell Sophie you know
that the Vale can play an interesting
role because they aren't actually loyal
they like Roy old yeah they've taken a
step back going where we have an
impenetrable fortress we don't want a
part of it we don't have a wall you guys
can fight amongst my wife up here it's a
great point you're making
because the person in charge at the time
was a pathetic snotty little TV sucking
boy boy and his mama she was scared
fighting and the men beneath Eric up the
parent right but she also was parenting
all of her army yeah and they are
itching to fight they're one of the
greatest forces in Westeros yeah we want
to fight wait
so listen what torment I love we talked
about he's going on his way to Eastwatch
though East Lodge is potentially where
the Hound was having that vision and I
mean he's actually having great career
in commercials but but I hope he stays
in of it he's basically a flaming beacon
in the snow of winter yeah um that by
the way is a director trademark they do
say throughout this episode is he loves
dark dark dark shots with blame just
like the brightest flame you ever seen
even notes like a little while Amy's not
symbolically season as well it's not
over the entire game of 93 yeah you're
going to see Ice and Fire so much you're
gonna get sick of it
so let's move on just a little further
south where the Brotherhood is yeah
Brotherhood is I'm actually using back
out just a little bit just to kind of
give you some perspective almost
confusing where they were because you
were like oh there was a lot of snow
falling yeah around there that's the
Riverlands okay clean kid common winters
hit a lot for the south now also it
could be an instance of weather you know
that they're having but we noticed the
Riverlands because that's the place that
they previously had visited both found
and Arya yes and they saw that poor guy
and like oh man if you really remember
the events of that episode he steals his
silver and he's like well whatever
people would have come along and soul in
it it's fine and now they saw a dress
they ended it before they actually oh
yeah essentially he really was
responsible for what happened there but
if you go back and watch that episode
it's raining a lot during that time so
this is an area that also just there's
more moisture in there but as winter is
coming at is getting colder it's kind of
phrase over yeah rain is going to turn
into snow so it's why they're in a
blizzard it was just a little confusing
for some people words like isn't aria
not that far from there but hers is not
snow it's because of the weather's they
have in that area got it but getting
actually into the to what's going on
with this guy you always need a
refresher because these guys had a huge
focus was it season 3003 yeah
so the Brotherhood without banners in
the books is a little different put up a
not entirely different what's
fascinating that's not clear in the show
about them it is good if we're going to
do a refresher is that they
forms mostly from the people that were
at the hands tourney that we did see
where the mountain was knocked off his
horse by the knight of flowers yeah it
was not in one
oh yeah Mountain one which is actually
yeah different actors yeah completely
but also like a different dude he's like
changed a bit a little bit yeah
so that tourney was why all these
amazing fighters were in the area at the
time and then asked to create
essentially the Brotherhood without
banners to go and be force of justice
and so they actually are all like some
of the best fighters in the game yes now
of course at this point there's and they
don't look like they're doing so great
anymore and they actually addressed a
lot of things in a very like whatever
the audience is thinking they said it
and I kind of love that writing because
it's like yes for being obvious yes you
know you obviously know where this is
going so we'll just make it obvious for
you so the writing this episode was
great and I'm obviously always last
season a new season very wary because
I've got nothing to go on
so the Brotherhood right now is
definitely gonna play a larger role and
then I think really it's going to be to
facilitate the hounds role this season
so he's actually another character I
want to talk about what the arc is going
to be and where we have him right now
versus where he's going to go so we find
him a man without faith he actually
can't even remember the words to the the
news right but also very guilty he's
responsible for the death these people
so I think it's very clear my want guess
for him what they didn't try to do is
just get Redemption whatever I need to
do to just be redeemed for the terrible
things I've done if he is or hi mmm
eerie video and he's come back in a way
he can't die this man should have died
time and time again he works for Joffrey
is like a hitman although if he did so
many tasks that he knows taken on so
many people at a time Brienne left him
for dead
this guy can't die now I was like beric
Dondarrion as well who knows you've got
a higher purpose he just has no idea
what it is and a flaming sword that's
been a lot up this vision I'm excited
about but yeah I mean could that be the
biggest like ironic moment out of this
whole thing he is the flaming prophet
all right right well they called that
out I love that way of course I'm like
that I got a fire yeah you can see the
flames guys you can see it perfectly in
it
yeah I also love that listen to the
flame so like 10 seconds and he's like
I'm having vision I can see everything
there that was too easy
but how did baratunde Aaron notice oh no
that was the priest who said look into
the flames or can you see it they just
looked look knowing almost so how we be
able to see it
well Thoreau SIA is a priest of the Lord
of Light he may be he does have a good
feeling about the Hound this is the
second time that caused the cross
there's no such things as accidents any
more coincidences I found this happen
here so there's definitely a larger
destiny ahead of this guy which is why I
actually feel like elevating him to the
role of a character I wanted to watch
week to week where's this guy headed
there's definitely something up here if
they headed to Eastwatch as well could
they run into torment and the free folk
and they could all team up under the
banners Brotherhood potentially we know
that they're headed north we don't know
they're clear mission yet but it feels
like they're kind of like guys running
White Walkers us too yeah I think that's
kind of roughly what their mission is
trending so moving just a little bit
adjacent in still kind of the Riverlands
we saw her at the twins at the beginning
of the episode but we know she's on her
way to King's Landing is of course Arya
and oh man Arya is like having her own
little side story here where she's also
going going on this tremendous arc so
where do we find Arya right when the
season starts this is fantastic we see
her as Walder Frey so we don't know that
it's Aria why at all you just see well
basically talk to all of these men and
you know you see chintz throughout this
entire thing he dresses in joy you know
I think that's where divulge ever
another face you know for not you might
be wondering why my hands are a little
smaller than they used to be anything
that seems off about me is fine you're
just you know I'm a little under the
weather and thank you for using the word
fortnight because it is real America I
use it all the time oh really the word
for two weeks
yes it's so good people laugh at me when
I use it but multiplied does I called it
a wooly novel that's not true I tried
Wow have long dating I am not at all
anyway she poisons them all but she
delivers this lawn which i think is
absolutely fantastic and I'm probably
misquoting it because that's what I do
basically you even if you let one will
scar the shape on place what is the
actual quote that'll do big tying it in
with your friendship is a
and that is a baby court system that
will do picked Assad so that's what I
really find fascinating about that is
she's essentially saying the mistake you
made is that you didn't kill every Stark
so who is the polar opposite of that Ned
Stark do you remember how he was
actually the one that stood up against
Robert Robert wanted to kill every last
Targaryen and Ned's the one saying you
know what that's a little girl you're
talking about a lot and good example or
invalid and and it's going to happen
with the Targaryen but here's the other
little girl that you didn't kill and she
came back the big thing as well that I
still identifies as a stark first and
foremost and that is an identity that
even if you change faces that one thing
stays true what I was a questioning
throughout this episode she's so close
to reuniting with her bastard brother
and sister someone that you know she
obviously would be drawn to first and
foremost so that a list is more
important you're totally nailing I think
what is going to be happening across
this got it right here
she don't given that about her already
and I think Sheeran men [ __ ] important
she cares about vengeance
right yeah I think where she's headed to
and why she meets these Lannister
soldiers actually is because she has to
realize oh right I'm not just this force
of killing there are good people here
she looked longingly when the guy's
thinking about his father on the ship
the other guy talks about his newborn
baby and she's kind of like oh I forgot
what about my family and my purpose and
like I am she just seems so lonely in
the ointment from no one to a stark
again maybe it's headed I also want to
and you guys can help with this one
using the hashtag-- of Westeros weekly
what could kill this is going to be per
episode if I'm the welder and all of the
phrase who's going to be next on the
literally a Mina Cersei yes but there's
two people on that least that she could
be getting to on her way down but and
some of them have already naturally died
she's figured out who that's on the list
so that'll be good a good thing look at
our breakdown for two as an update or
who's on the list
yeah so I think we're re it out a little
bit but look at this massive
yes going on over here yeah well I
really just one of my favorite reasons
to have a map for this look how close
everyone is I still on that be Bruin oh
that's the show sir was obvious right
we've got the Lannisters and King's
Landing and Kings Landing by the way is
all like Lannisters their favorite
football team now every single sigil is
that was quick
all those brassy and hold on Oh God
Lannister now and there's a beautiful
moment there where Jamie still is in
mourning he goes do we going to talk
about Tommen is it's a conversation
which I was watching I was like you're
gonna talk about Salman and she's just
like not moving on there's bigger things
here Andros misses this power lust that
she's on where it's like you know what I
use my children to get there now that
they're gone I'm here and that's all
that matters she didn't feel that way at
the time but now she's since realized
well if this is how it's gonna go then
fine I'm gonna embrace her hundred
percent so we got the Lannisters there
now we've got your on Greyjoy right in
the bay just land landen right now and
here we'll talk about him in a second
how he's quite the character now yeah
there's an interesting part pea where he
goes at the end of last season I'm going
to take it to the Queen and she can you
know that right herb is I didn't
actually identify which Queen it was so
I think still Daenerys is who he was
talking about but he since learned that
Daenerys has already formed alliance
with his traitorous sibling order and
that's what he's trying to now have
common ground with what set is that I
don't think Cersei knows she's number
two on the list he's all he did was
change his plan I'm gonna give this to a
slightly different blondish clean yeah
cause he wanted the most attractive
woman in the whole land and that is done
err did did Daenerys sorry I said D like
nineteen unity unit
it wasn't Monterey Tyrell got rid of her
because she was the up-and-coming Queen
that my elders Muriel's a little you
know anyway
the Katie Holmes kind of thing going
okay button it then it's Daenerys
Targaryen so gosh you know the thread of
the beautiful Queen as well it's
happening so we have your on there over
here you pay the full cost this is
exactly the hot Sun and a seam of Dragon
um we don't just have the Martel's we
actually have an alliance with this
right yeah they're so they're right
there in some of the
[ __ ] and then right above them is of
course at Dragonstone having landed is
freaking Daenerys Targaryen
this is game-changing yes Westeros and
she's down the street from King's
Landing this is the second arrises army
keeps going from strength to strength it
started with the unsullied then she
moved into taking over most of airsoft
in a way which I think it's just kind of
crumbled to the point where she's like
male well she left her lover boy Daario
naharis ferret is Daario yeah let's go
ahead and talk about Daenerys pinellas
name she had it's interesting you talk
about she's been collecting these armies
the same way that the knight Kings been
doing it just like a massing of course
everywhere he goes of course hers are
alive and free now and they're the
opposite so but we found her she's
landed at her home the place that she
has the most connection to and yet
doesn't actually know what it all
rangering her and yet everything is
dragon formed which I love which was so
awkward first Stannis when he lived
there was like man had a lot of dragon
here I'll go for me so we found her
finally at the like may be the beginning
of the story she's been waiting to go on
yeah so what's her specific goal that
she's gonna be going this season I think
it can happen sooner or later about
King's Landing because they still people
are pushing it her in that direction
King's Landing is the way consists of a
bane
I think the time to strike is now that
is a direct quote from Yara I think that
because we see her linger on the table
that belonged to Aegon Targaryen her
gegege grandfather when he landed at
Dragonstone and informed this whole
place and he planned his exact invasion
which is exactly what she was planning
to do so strategically a hunted
something amazing I think is so
interesting so he also had three dragons
he had three writers himself including
his two sisters so who's the three
writers for Daenerys very interesting
but he split his dragon force he didn't
send him all of the same play and so I
think strategy like that is actually
what she's trying to figure out now
that's where she's gonna land if not
okay now let's bum-rush it she's not
gonna Leroy Jenkins yeah yeah no Leroy
you're sick man
Amon what dish what is her knowledge
with the North right now because that is
the biggest threat and she is the most
obvious solution to that threat
what she doesn't know right now is that
she's sitting on the perfect weapon and
materials to defeat the north now this
is that's where Dragonstone is it's
literally with the dragon class yeah
it's built on top of it and if you
notice when they the ships pull into the
side and she has that little moment with
the sand the coast line goes from a
stark dark color to a natural rock face
that jagged almost Fortress of Solitude
look yeah I'm guessing that that's the
dragon gossiped yeah well it looks
exactly like what Sam has in his book it
also looks exactly like the throne that
she encounters in there so because Sam
has written to John stating where the
dragon class is which is Dragonstone
landing dragon I want to call the dragon
yeah Jackie's landing is better like a
helicopter pad yeah what does this mean
who is John going to send to retrieve or
what's happening there because that's
going to unite another force at her
headquarters well he's going to go there
thank you my guess and be like hey girl
you got something I want I mean he's
gonna find out the truth daddy's
heritage and then are they gonna have a
moment they're gonna zap is Bren gonna
come in here and be like oh by the way I
went back in time and found out oh poor
Meera she dragged my god all the way
done mom and we're still actually hot
what does she know her John have no
communication he knows nothing like him
so she knows nothing Johnston right but
he knows something
now he's gonna bring it to her as my
guest but the really interesting thing
is look what happens when you have
people united and yet some of them have
encountered the debt and fought them and
some of them haven't and if there's
between Sansa and John yeah she's like
yeah yeah there's an issue but then Ryan
you know now the number I'll take care
of that I'm like nobody's ever ever
successfully attacked the north of one
time they felt because the guy kneeled
you know like it's very hard to attack
the north how about you worry about
monsters
yeah you know and I did watch Sam is
facing because he obviously had direct
contact he's killed a white Walker or a
white and he's trying to convince all
these mesas that are supposed to be the
world of knowledge he's like they're
real I need to the solution to fight
them connect please have access well
speaking if we can hop over there for a
sec I don't think there's that much to
say about the Greyjoy's or tarinai at
this time no I'll be following so just a
point out way away from the action all
the way in the southwest
corner of Westeros that's where we find
mr. Samwell Tarly and little baby
Samwell Tarly
and Mama Gilly and big surprise - or
Mormont yeah if you didn't recognize his
hand you recognize this double shot I
was a beautiful yeah in the still okay
well he's gotta go yeah yeah his voice
is like the dragon well she's like so
like he's becoming it does drive you mad
it's like syphilis not from experience
it's just something that happened a lot
of history to Lauren old episode that
really nailed what was yeah Oh Alan
crazy and killed it on anyway um
what I noticed about the skin though is
that when you saw it on Shireen even I
had been contained it was hardened like
scales in this particular case his skin
it's flaking off as if he's shedding I
think it's it that's one step what we're
gonna have to reference the medical
texts that are in old town there behind
a gate when you said essentially I think
that I never want to go to old town it
looks very beautiful and picturesque
walls of books this beautiful like
magnifying glass that manipulates light
so it's all flowing down and then
everyone shoots their face off yeah why
are they doing this we I guess they're
all old as hell how do you sleep over
that oh but that really happened that's
action idea behind anyway uh so Samwell
is not someone that I want to
necessarily cover the entire art I do
have the question of what does he work
on now because he figured out the
dragonglass
yeah it's kind of like alright cuz I'm
gonna go to the beach like you know how
a story a lot of people in the comments
we're saying that he's just gonna die
like when does he die Wow
Sam well yank a killer with you the kids
like a blue boy now he's as a tasting
room ready just like is like I'm a baby
shirt but this is an interesting thing
and I'd love to hear from you guys what
do you think Sam is going to be up to
did you even but I think it's worth
really quick just really hitting home
what is going to happen between these
two nothing good
Cersei and Jaime I know we've kind of
touched on earlier but I think I really
wanted to like nail down Cersei asked
him if he was afraid and he didn't
exactly say no no he I feel like he's
taking up the mantle and he goes you
know what if she's going to be crazy
I need to step up and be the voice of
reason here which is why he's kind of
like orchestrating some things happening
in the court
I think the Maggie frog prediction is
going to surface this season other
minute so it's almost done right yeah
well there were three things are
happening one of them with someone
younger and prettier will to take over
yep
she got rid of her where children would
all die yeah they've all died and the
last one is will die at the hands of her
younger brother the valonqar and she's
got two younger brothers technically
Jamie came out of the womb after her
even though they're twins and Tyrion who
is you know he's a little choking people
he has done it before and little brother
yes like at the hands of the trio mod
Derek came up with this prophecy words
like your little brother no because I'm
not an awful person
but I do want to point out that the
hands going at the hands of the under
brother Jamie's only got one did that
rules him out when like a song you
really could I thought I was well and
then of course it would make him turn to
on the people that he's sworn to protect
King Slayer becoming Queen Slayer
somebody asked us the question I think
it's he knows I become a team player
Oh dr. G someone asked us a question
that is so good yeah what if Arya
takes on Jamie's face and that's where
she's headed she's realized if she takes
the face of someone who no one would
suspect she can do the bend and most
damage what if she put on Jamie's face
and didn't have the golden hand with
fully-formed
died at the hands of the younger brother
I mean that idea is just so fast I
didn't like I don't even think we should
like really talk about it too much just
it'll happen yeah that's what happens
right we did that because you planted
that seed and we all yeah yeah that line
out really quick a force of chaos and
I'm saying that on purpose because to me
he was very much reminiscent of the
Joker is you're on Greyjoy now you're on
definitely last season was kind of just
like hey I'm a tough guy or whatever and
I'm gonna kill me brother he definitely
looks like a rock star
yes oh my gosh he's in a British punk
band Yeah right I think he was wearing
eyeliner
ah no and
fit the image of him and the books a lot
more he's addicted to essentially the
equivalent of like heroin just like any
head rockstar is not terrible but that
what did you think of his attempt at
seducing Cersei this guy's lost he's
lost his army he's lost his power he had
got new ships and he was using that as a
ploy to gain a status and there's not
many people that he can team up with
he's got to win Sophie over there's
nothing else that he can do at this
stage what I've noticed with the writing
and with the depictions of what Cersei
is up to and what you're on done you're
on Tim Yara you're on TMZ on eons gone
through so much he needs he needs
justice but you're on who's come in here
and is just shook things up in the worst
way you're not rooting for him you hate
thirsty you want these two to team up
and to think that they've got hope for
it to be completely snuffed out and we
both wiped out potentially but I don't
think that would happen till the end of
the season because to me they're agents
of chaos everything feels like it's
going according to plan the theme of
this episode again had a lot to do with
setting the places getting everything
ready and then you just throw these two
and who are to me right now being the
Joker and kind of Harley Quinn of Harley
Quinn was even more like a killer and
the two of them together I think are
really going to cause some damage now it
seems like Cersei isn't into it but I
think she's gonna fall for crazy real
hard specifically because someone asked
us
what's your on gifts gonna be yeah I
think it's going to be a good gift I
think it could be all man say it could
be Tyrion yeah I think it could be
cheery addressed that same person made a
really good point Tyrion has a bad habit
of being caught yeah like you've been
kidnapped how many times now he's not
far away they pretty much depending on
him next door to each other yeah but
it's definitely feasible kill him I
don't think so I don't think neurons
going to kill Tyrion and it's just ahead
I don't think that's going to happen
they're called too much and invested too
much in the character of Tyrion
I think Tyrians maybe at King's Landing
and that's where she could end little
brother who knows it would be better
Fanny to put them all there and if they
all right which little brother's going
to get to her first
but yeah it's definitely like a really
nice carrot that they're dangling I'm
going to bring you a gift and that will
score you you know your hand in my hand
in marriage whatever that is but you're
right so she's so mad she's hearing a
lot of nose from Jamie she wants someone
else that's matching her crazy and
you're on just like let's ask them
and she's like done I love oh I know
exactly you said even though you kept a
family family
we're gonna ask the mess up mm-hmm
Bridget eyes are coming next week for
this next part of the show we're just
gonna go over some of your guys's
questions we answer some throughout put
some that I think are pretty fascinating
so at chocolate gold wants to know do
you think its stance of challenging
John's decisions could actually
strengthen their relationship rather
than weaken it the conversation that I
had about it when I first started has
with you know huge bang don't question
me that's not cool and her saying well
maybe just listen to me and there was a
sense of compromise that sounds like
they are working with each other and
they both want the same thing at the end
of the day I think that sums I could
disagree too many times with John and
they want to take over so eventually I'm
thinking it's going to weaken the two
interesting eventually I'm not sure
right now it's not in a bad place bandit
isn't together could do great things
yeah but that's probably why it won't
happen too much of a good thing all
right that's good answer I'm onboard
huh at Sarah oh oh oh sorry
it's a you a you Oh Sarah she wonders
what's gonna happen at Ed Sheeran next
now here's the fascinating can I get
back to you singing what is fascinating
about that scene is that it's obviously
trying to be like Oh Arya's remembering
her humanity and love and goodness and
men how cool would it be of next week's
guide sharing space on she's just like
yeah I'm too far gone I think if they
wanted to subvert expectations they
would just be like nope no coming back
for Arya she kills them
they're Lannisters she hates Lannisters
but you know real people and I think
that she's realized maybe on the back of
killing every nail fray right she's like
wow I just killed someone husband
someone father you know I absolutely am
on board with thinking that's what they
want us to think and that's where it's
probably headed but oh boy what if I
gone did you have any good palate
Sandhya hmm
all right so this is the last question
we'll take on this show but Eric's
actually going to answer some other
questions in his breakdown make sure you
watch it it's going to be so good we've
been talking all day about stuff that's
going in there okay but this is from at
nema n several references episode to the
imperviousness of the wall it is
foreshadowing its demise it was not
subtle spoon-feeding but I did notice
that they were being mentions of it it
happened in Old Town with Samantha who
just you know said if noone ever ever
comes down what could happen something
is going to happen and I love those
shots those sweeping shots they have of
the wall like you do see how big it is
that scale where the gates open up and
you realize it is only really this far
out of this much I love it this director
loves it ultra wide shots and giving you
on at the wall it is an amazing one yeah
I think it's coming down
something's happening even if it's just
in that corner maybe there's some sort
of weakness where the wall meets the sea
and it's so far away that the Nights
Watch is never gonna see it you know
they're combo like from one side all the
way over oh god it's gonna be insane
alright and then so we're going to wrap
up we got two things that we're going to
do every week our Power Rankings
remember I asked you guys to vote in a
poll we also use a little bit of our own
secret sauce what we do is we account
for who has the most blood on their
hands yeah in each episode just because
political influence in the game of
Thrones is one part of the game then
Littlefinger would be way higher up than
you would expect yeah you also got to
talk about brute force so we're going to
you guys to the poll of just who has the
most influence and Westeros but then
we're also keeping track of literally
body counts and we're going to use that
as a factor into determining who it's
going to be so coming in at number three
according to you guys and us is
surprisingly Daenerys Targaryen I know I
thought should be at the top I think
that she's got the best and biggest army
I think that she's the one who's got the
most power and influence at the moment
but she hasn't got much blood on her
hand yeah so during also in this episode
specifically she is not a formidable
force on display it's just kind of like
hey I've taken over this scene over you
going on here I think it's very specific
that she pulls down the Baratheon sigil
and like okay I own this castle now it's
like going like Starcraft errs on man
taking over like a base
nerd exactly
what's happened is that she has
influenced a particular land a lot of
his adjusting but it's not in this
episode making anybody quake so number
two is Jon Snow now John is very
interesting choice because he does have
the North pretty form firmly United yeah
and the Vale Dan Gambas that guy's got
huge numbers right now and I do support
him they are listening to him even
though they love to challenge him and
sense is now challenging him as well but
people are saying that he is the king of
the north you know right so doc King
Ghidorah
oh yeah Kings in the games not which is
fascinating because when we caught him
last time this director actually
directed the episode killed a boy which
was when John has become the Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch and he has
to make the same choice essentially
about annoying walkers and everybody
freakin hates them including Ollie and
he has no support and Maester Aemon even
tells him to do it and he's like it'll
be fine and it'll he was not fine yeah
he's in the exact same situation now and
he's making this this bold choice and
people are like alright we're going to
put Spears in the hands of our little
girls so he really has influence he had
a most traditional way but he doesn't
have the body count not also political
influence of number one Arya Stark yeah
this week now this is the thing unlike
John and Daenerys she doesn't have an
army backing her she is the lone
assassin here but she's realized that
with these newfound powers she can cause
the most damage and she's got the blood
on her hands
it's funny when were talking about who
died this episode of like no one know I
didn't see any blood oh yeah that's
right that was wrong fifty people came
in she's just cleared out basically like
the phrase as a whole right so exhibits
the part to underline a lot of people
might think well she had a lot of blood
on her hands sure is that really winning
the game of Thrones this week think
about for a second of political impact
at that had you had surcease pay we've
you know I'm on the Queen of the Seven
Kingdoms and Jamie saying all three at
best one of those with the phrase right
that's I think that's the ads best right
that's why those Lannister soldiers are
in the Riverlands right now they're like
we heard some stuff is going down with
the fray mediated for title oriented
bring the Queen's peace there so really
specifically the whole area
that she just impacted the Riverlands
the phrase were running the twins they
also all the lanes of the Tully's were
under Walder Frey as well with the
entire Frey family gone the the road to
the north might hold I mean hasn't yet
but might completely shift directions
and be completely lost to Cersei and
Lannister
I could remember in season 3 as the
twins was the passageway between the
north and south she has basically
destroyed the that locked off access
that's free rein now to get from the
south to the north and the north to the
south potentially it depends on who
takes it who takes our who else have we
got there the end of last season was all
about Edmund being held hostage and all
of catlins extended family who were
always fundamentally loyal to the Starks
right so and I have directly for the
Tully's to like they've murdered Adam
your sister you know so that's why Arya
wins this week not only did she kill 50
freaking people she wiped out a house
that was strategically a very important
house in the overall brought if you
extend the map out the North has gone
from being just there to here well it's
like the top top of this Bay we could
yeah right and that's the choke - when
you're talking about which they refer to
as the neck you're right depending on
who's in control of that you can only go
in one direction kind of I so previously
Circe's threat kind of made some sense
yeah that she could go through there but
also it's one road the kings roads are
there it's one major castle the big part
of it right now we can't predict how
that neck is going to settle but it's
just throat she's throwing as Aziz and
English people say a spanner in the work
that's made up that's that's a real
afraid all right and then finally let's
watch a preview for next week's episode
targaryen cannot be trusted the mad
Kings daughters will destroy the realm
we have an army a fleet and three
dragons which is hitting landing now
[Music]
so to break it down whoo why does this
guy in the north here
Daenerys I want to know how that
information can I give you something
crazy yeah he says a Targaryen cannot be
trusted
what if John's Heritage's come out and
he's not talking about tenaris oh that's
a great counter-argument that's
definitely I I'm not saying it is that
but we we see a moment where
Littlefinger gets choked yeah it looks
like Don's choking him yep has little
fingers revealed his heritage maybe my
god he always keeps those because his
power is information and he's right now
backed into a corner a little bit like
Santa isn't exactly listening to him oh
my gosh because if he did denies John
being a stark then he can't be the ruler
of the North Santa has to be he's going
to move his way into Santa so it's
basically and later agenda and that's
Royce though remember Royce is just like
a stupid hard-ass I just want to go to
problem with everything look at my big
shell like yes no one no one else is
wearing that that armor is not in right
now - ha ha these you've also seen a
little sympathy a yarra obviously
wanting to get Westeros dominated and
she makes a very very good point free
dragon but what you brought up with the
whole it's splitting or TJ clearity
martyr just split the force you know
there's a lot of strategy that can go
into deciding where you put your your
pieces
it's the Alexander the great famous
strategy when you surround your army on
all sides so that they're stuck in the
middle and you just keep going in until
they're gone whoo man whoo while she was
talking who else thought about all the
bastards exactly exactly this is a big
thing that happens all the time a couple
of little things as well if you do it
scream if you pulls at the right moment
Yara looks like to get night on with
glorious fam yeah why not one man I love
it and one slings one is Alejandra
presiding I'll go ahead ilaria is so
funny where she did say when she stabbed
what's-his-name last or inmortal
no man will ever rule here again but
she's all about ladies
yeah and uniting it sure cool she's
gonna back to narrows female Rella
but and then she and she hates Cersei Oh
hundreds Angela Dora right poison very
lovely oh good yeah you're not good and
I thought I roll teaming up with Dorne
is the same thing
I love oh my gosh there's other horror
and weird yeah yeah so screwed and the
other the point in there we saw in the
mirror hopefully maybe you thought a
direwolf cervical area so good were like
yeah so next week looks like it's going
to be about executing strategy this
episode was a lot about setting the
pieces yeah I think it's about executing
it but I don't think it's going to go
according to plan
that's my prediction for next week
you're right it's usually set up
execution setup execution and I think we
will see some sort of execution the
question is a little persons I'm sure
you like it and maybe a grade or battle
neuron has been Westeros weekly thank
you so much for suggesting that we do
this because I love Game of Thrones
loves talking about Game of Thrones I
don't think we get tired of [ __ ] no I
was so excited its back use that hashtag
Westeros weekly if you do when I talked
about those questions connect with us at
all in all working with my juice at mode
Garrett's work you want subscribe to my
channel geek bomb it we should go come
for such each bomb and I say geek
apparently in my accent it sounds like
dick dick bomb yeah
get bomb geek bum bum in a bomb bomb I
hit me up at fimo and again if there's
anything we didn't answer here we
probably lines heard in the breakdown go
watch that it's gonna be so good see you
next time
ye
you